one for nine he has four turnovers as  well  paul whips it back crowder knocks it  down  [Applause]  here is paul the pull-up he's  good that is just not a way to guard  chris paul  and he just takes his time runs time off  the clock and gets the shot that they  want every time  paul again the mid-range  maestro i'm trying to tell you you don't  want to guard chris ball that way  you've seen it a few times but chris  paul going to his right that little  pull-up  is automatic denver still with some life  down 15. barton lost it paul  again with the snatch from behind  and then the no look into crowder just  got it away  crowder to the corner five to shoot  bridges gives it back look at that  ball alone you yeah  that's 30 points 19 rebounds nine  assists for jokic  booker given a lane floats it in  timeout denver that's it  market time of death 10 27  mountain time the phoenix suns have  taken complete  control of this game